>>Joe Malin: Hello and welcome, once again,
to Android developer office hours.
My name is Joe Malin and with me is Alexander
Lucas and also Trevor Johns.
>>Trevor Johns: Howdy everyone.
>>Joe Malin: Our engineer today is Daniel
Pham.
And without further ado let’s go to moderator
and see what our first question for the day
is.
>>Trevor Johns: Actually, we should mention
one thing before we get started.
Last weekend we said that this week we would
have--
>>Joe Malin: Oh, that’s right.
>>Trevor Johns: guests from security joining
us today but, unfortunately, they had some
other things going on and unfortunately we
had to cancel that.
So this week we’re just gonna be holding
a general office hours.
It will not be security focused.
So any questions that you have whatsoever,
on any topic, concerning Android of course,
we’ll be happy to answer them.
And hopefully, at some point in the future,
we’ll actually be able to get the folks from
security back on and we’ll reschedule that.
>>Joe Malin: Great.
Thank you, Trevor, for that announcement.
Now, can we ask the first question?
Which is, “What is the best technique to
do location aware notifications?
I’ve tried to use location manager and proximity
alert but it keeps the GPS always on, at least
on Jelly Bean, and seems not to respect the
documentation when the phone is with screen
off.” I’m not sure what that means, but
in any event we need some hints here.
Anybody wanna answer?
>>Trevor Johns: Sure.
I can take that.
So, whenever you’re requesting location notifications
the phone does have to keep, you know, keep
pulling for some sort of location data.
And, in general, the answer here is to make
sure that location data is not coming from
GPS cause GPS is gonna be your biggest power
sink.
If you request the course location provider,
that will use the network, the network location
services so, typically, that’s things like
Wi-Fi geo location and that sort of stuff
and the power consumption there is significantly
reduced compared to GPS.
So, apps like Google Now use that trick.
They actually do not turn on GPS except in
very rare circumstances.
So that way, again, power consumption is minimized
and you keep your users happy.
So, that’s the answer.
Make sure you’re using the course location
prog- or make sure you set, you know, course
as your requested resolution when you’re
requ--, when you’re schedu--, when you’re
asking for location updates.
>>Joe Malin: Great, thank you, Trevor.
Any other comments?
Nope?
Alright, we’ll move on.
“Let’s say I wanna add a feature to my app
like SMS integration, rather than scaring
people off with that permission should I make
a second shell app that has the permission
and same shared user ID that they can optionally
install, or should I do something else?”
>>Alex Lucas: Okay, I can take this one.
So, first, I should say it’s really, it’s
good that you’re, that you have, that you’re
approaching this with the attitude of not
wanting to scare people off with extraneous
permissions.
That said, the, if you think about this from
the perspective of a user, if they download
an app that does not have SMS permissions
and, you know, less scary, that app then says,
“Hey, download my buddy app that has, you
know, is slightly skeezier” you’re gonna
come off as a Trojan horse and it’s going
to be, it’s going to look even sketchier
than if you had included the SMS integration
in the first place.
What you wanna do, it, the correct solution,
a lot of it depends on the details of like
what you’re integrating SMS for.
If it is, if you’re just trying to send messages
to people you might wanna abandon, or you
might want to avoid having SMS built into
your own app and you might just wanna intent
when you’re sending SMS messages out.
If you’re reading incoming SMS messages then
the best solution there is to just add the
permission to your app and within the description
of the app explain what you’re using the
permission for.
That said, you should only have to explain
it if it, if it, if it isn’t immediately
apparent from the description of your app.
Like, if your app is something that turns
the phone on or off or plays music based on
an incoming SMS message you don’t need to
explain the permission, people understand
I interact with SMS, therefore I need the
SMS permission.
If you’re a flashlight app you shouldn’t
have an SMS permission in the first place.
So the, what, your solution is going to depend
on what your app is but the whole second app
installation thing is definitely the wrong
way to go.
>>Trevor Johns: Right.
I mean, just to elaborate a little bit on
what Alex said there, if the core purpose
of your app is not sending SMS, you should
avoid meddling SMS functionality into your
app and, instead, use intents to delegate
to another application whose job is to send
SMS.
And, besides the obvious that, you know, the
issue of permissions, there’s a second reason
you wanna do that and that’s because of the
user experience.
A lot of time, Google Voice is a prime example
here; users will install some other app that
are responsible for sending text messages.
Most of the time those are apps that do go
and use the normal SMS infrastructure and
they send it through their cell carrier but,
again, in the case of Google Voice those messages
are actually routed over the internet and
don’t use the normal telephony stack on the
phone.
And if you don’t use the SMS intent the SMS
messages will not be sent through the user’s
desired SMS handler and that might not be
something they want.
So you could be sending the SMS messages from
the wrong phone number in that case.
So please, please, please use intent whenever
possible and you’ll make your life easier
and you’ll make your users so much happier.
>>Joe Malin: Great.
Thank you, Trevor.
Next question, “Is there a way to measure
the power consumption of the location manager
caused by my app?
As location based to do that it has to create
a location regularly but it doesn’t appear
in the battery stats.
How can I measure power optimizations for
it?”
>>Alex Lucas: Hm, to answer the first sub
question of the overall set of questions,
measuring, I don’t believe it’s currently
possible to measure the power consumption
in location manager that’s caused by your
app specifically.
>>Trevor Johns: Oh, no, it’s possible to
measure your app but the--
>>Alex Lucas: But it’s the consumption going
through the location manager.
>>Trevor Johns: Right.
Yeah, location manager is not going to be
bundled together with your app, so--
>>Alex Lucas: Right, it’s--
>>Trevor Johns: You’re not gonna get the
stats you want there.
I can explain how we do it on the Android
edge team and it’s a little bit cumbersome.
We have a box that actually measures current
draw from the phone and so we’ll plug a phone
into that instead of to a battery, you know,
it goes where the battery contacts normally
would be.
And then we’ll measure the actual power consumption
coming out of the device.
So this is a harder solution and it is a bit
specialized but that’s gonna get you the
most accurate numbers.
Hopefully for some future release of Android
we’ll go and improve the reporting.
We’re always trying to go and give developers
more metrics especially for something as critical
as batter life.
But, unfortunately right now the feature you’re
looking for just isn’t a part of Android.
So, sorry about that, hopefully we’ll get
to it for ya.
>>Alex Lucas: I don’t know how helpful the
magic box is going to be for a location based
application like that.
>>Trevor Johns: Well, it would give you the
numbers.
I mean, it’s going to be a weird test rig.
It’s not something you wanna leave plugged
in all the time but it is an engineering tool
and if that’s the only option then, unfortunately,
that’s the only option.
>>Joe Malin: Okay, any other comments?
No?
The next question is, “Need to connect to
a legacy SOAP web service over https, service
doesn’t support O auth tokens, etcetera.
So I need to have username, password, once
entered is there any way to store the user’s
log in credentials securely to prevent having
to enter them again?” And there was some
comments put in to--
>>Trevor Johns: Right, the comments from Christian
in Germany was that you should use a custom
account and then take a look inside of Android
training, there’s a, well first off there’s
a custom auth section in Android training
and there’s also a sample to sink it after.
And then there’s a second part, we’ll get
to that in a moment, and that’s partially
correct.
A custom account would get you a secure location
to store credentials.
That being said, it’s not strictly required.
And the reason for that, custom accounts are
more when you’re providing an account to
other services on the system or you have some
background sync job.
So, for example, if you have Picasa and Picasa
is the background going in and uploading your
photos, right, and you can use a sync adapter
and things like that.
Excellent choice for accounts, anytime you’re
exporting account data via account manager
so you want to provide your own, you know,
O auth handler to let users get auth tokens;
another excellent use for account manager.
But, it’s bit overkill if you’re just trying
to go in and secure passwords securely, or
store passwords securely somehow.
So, in that case, my usual recommendation
is just to go and create a preferences file
somewhere on the device, make sure it’s stored
on internal storage and that you’ve set it,
set the mode to private.
Every application on Android is given its
own unique user ID, just typical Android,
or typical unique ID and if you set the file
permissions to private, that means no other
application on the system will be able to
read that file except for your app.
And, so, that’s currently our recommended
best practice for secure password storage
assuming, again, you’re not falling into
these advanced use cases where account manager
makes sense and you’ll find that’s a lot
simpler.
So, as far as the second part of the question
was, “the authenticator stores the password
blank but you can encrypt it using MD5 or
SHA-1 and then decrypt it later.” And, I
hate to tell you, but that’s actually not
gonna work.
[Laughs]
>>Trevor Johns: MT5 and SHA-1 are what’s
referred to as cryptographic hash functions
and cryptographic hash functions are designed
to be one way and there’s a bunch of other
fun properties to them too but what that means
is, you can take some source text, feed it
through, again, MD5 or SHA-1, you’ll get
your hash out and there’s no way to go back
from that hash and get your original text
back.
For one, they’re fixed link hashes so the
output is always gonna be the same number
of characters.
You can imagine if you feed in a lot of data,
if I feed it, if I feed in a megabyte of data
and I get back a 160 bytes, actually, I think
it’s 160 bits, in the case of SHA-1 I believe,
don’t quote me on that.
In any case, you’re losing data.
It’s just simply not possible to go and recover
the original password if you use those.
You could go and use something like AES and
that’s a, a symmetric cipher which will let
you go and create some secret key embedded
inside your APK and then write that to disc
and then later unencrypt, again, using that
same secret key inside of your APK and that
would give you a little bit extra security.
I think in most cases using the file permissions
built into Android is enough.
In the exceptional case where you have a user
that’s rooted their device and there’s a
malicious app on the device that’s taking
advantage of this to break out of the sandbox
and read from other files.
This would protect you against this as long
as it’s not a targeted attack.
But, for general purpose, that’s gonna be
more than enough security for most users and,
at this point, we’re falling into an edge
case within an edge case.
So, I think using something like AES to go
and secure your password cache on the device
is not a bad idea, definitely do it.
And I think that’s the extent of Christian’s
comments and I think we’ve answered that
quite well as well, so.
>>Joe Malin: Yep.
>>Trevor Johns: Let’s move on.
>>Joe Malin: Okay.
>>Daniel Pham: I’ve actually got a question
from Chris who is in the hangout.
I’m gonna put him on, he doesn’t have video
but we’re gonna go, route his sound through
in a second.
>>Joe Malin: Alright.
>>Daniel Pham: Just give me one second.
Hey Chris, you’re on air, can you hear?
>>Chris: Yeah I can hear you, can you hear
me?
>>Joe Malin: Yep.
>>Trevor Johns: Hey Chris.
>>Chris: Okay, great.
Basically I’m using a phone content filter
URI to do a search and I’m passing either
a name or a number; just looking for matching
either phone numbers or names when doing a
search.
I noticed that in certain cases someone has
a phone number like 9951 and I search for
the letter zx, it ends up matching.
And that’s not anywhere, but it’s on multiple
devices.
>>Trevor Johns: That’s really interesting.
You’re just looking for, like, the like typical
telephone URI to go and match the phone number?
>>Chris: Yes.
>>Trevor Johns: Huh, I’m surprised that matches.
And just to make sure, it’s not doing something
really smart like trying to match where the
numbers zx would normally be on a telephone
keypad, correct?
>>Chris: Right, I’m not trying to, basically
all I’m trying, sorry, I’m trying to match
either the name or the number and there’s
no zx in the contact, it could just be like
a single phone number and, I mean, I’ve got
some sample code I could paste in but it’s
pretty straight forward what I’m searching
for.
I just wanna make sure that I’m allowed to
search for names; it matches the names like
if I type in Chris it does return all the
Chris results.
>>Alex Lucas: So if the zx being compared
to the phone number and returning positively?
>>Chris: Yes.
If I remove the phone, if I remove that phone
number it no longer matches.
>>Alex Lucas: Okay, I do, this is a speculation
but I’ve had some experience with SQLite
not being super type safe in terms of it’ll
compare like integers to strings and the code
would then like take that string and assume
it’s a bunch of numbers and, like, break
it down by bytes.
So that might be what’s happening.
>>Chris: Okay, is that something I should
maybe reproduce and just send to, like, as
an open Android bug on that?
>>Alex Lucas: I think it’s more a quote unquote
feature not a bug.
It’s a function of SQLite
>>Chris: Okay.
>>Alex Lucas: Which we don’t actually write.
I think the best thing to do there is, let’s
see, I would just say like within your abstraction
code make sure you’re, make sure that the
phone number that you’re comparing, or crap,
I don’t know off the top of my head how to
deal with this one.
>>Trevor Johns: Yeah, I’m not enough of an
expert as to how SQLite searching works.
I mean, I think this is a perfectly reasonable
thing to bring up on the SQLite but tracker
and see what the developers there say about
how searching should work.
That said, you’re gonna have to go and make
sure you explain it in the context of SQLite,
not Android.
And it’s entirely possible they might say
it’s a feature and not a bug.
But, you know, SQLite works the way SQLite
does on all platforms so our hands are tied
as to modifying the functionality there.
>>Joe Malin: I have a question; you said that
you’re using, to query phone.contentfilter.URI?
>>Chris: Yes.
>>Joe Malin: Okay, so phone is what’s the
parent class of phone?
>>Chris: I think its common data kinds, I
think.
>>Joe Malin: Okay.
I just wanted to check.
>>Chris: [inaudible]
>>Joe Malin: There’s so many different classes
in that package that, you know, um, I have
trouble keeping them apart.
>>Chris: Yeah, it is common data kinds.phone.contentfilteruri.
>>Joe Malin: Hold on, yeah I have to look
it up to see exactly what that thing does
but, I think you should be okay and I think
the data base thing that Alexander pointed
out is probably worth pursuing.
>>Chris: Okay.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
>>Daniel Pham: Alright, I actually have another
question for the hangout if that’s okay.
>>Joe Malin: Shoot.
>>Daniel Pham: Lucio I wanna put you on air,
give me one second.
[Pause]
>>Joe Malin: Hello?
>>Lucio: Hello.
So I tried to ask just for a course location
in my Android manifest but when I try to use
the proximity alert I get a secure exception
cause it asks for find location.
So I cannot use this API for media alert with
course location, only a final location.
>>Joe Malin: Which, no, there’s two different,
well I don’t know exactly what you’re doing
but there are two different permissions.
There’s an access--
>>Lucio: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
>>Joe Malin: Okay.
>>Lucio: Okay, what I’m doing is this, on
my manifest I requested for course location
permission and on my app I’m getting location
manager service and then calling proximity
alert on it.
Asking a location and a radius and then, but
only with course location I got a secured
exception cause this function needs find location.
But if I use find location it will always
get the GPS on and the activate [cannot understand]
>>Joe Malin: I under-, right, I understand.
Have you tried acc-, uh, tried requesting
both permissions?
>>Lucio: Yeah.
Requesting both permissions the GPS will always
be on and activated so--
>>Alex Lucas: So he only wants course permission,
right?
>>Joe Malin: He only wants course permission.
>>Lucio: Yeah, that’s what I was asking cause
I have to do something just like Google Now
with its location aware notifications where
the user comes close to some points and I
have to notify them but if I let, I lift the
find location my app with drain the users
battery and then they will be very sad and
not like it very much.
So I was thinking use the passive location?
>>Alex Lucas: Passive provider?
>>Lucio: Passive provider, yes, to gathering
all this information and maybe querying about
once in a while for the course location but
I don’t know, I would like to know how the
Google Now does this?
>>Trevor Johns: Well, that’s a good question
but I don’t think we can tell you how Google
Now does it on the air; you’d have to go
and look up the source code.
>>Alex Lucas: And get permission to talk about
how Google--
>>Trevor Johns: We can talk about how to use
the GPS that’s a system feature.
>>Alex Lucas: Probably.
>>Trevor Johns: But, in any case, I can’t
tell you exactly how Google Now does it right
off the top of my head.
We can certainly research it a bit more for
you and find out what the correct way to do
this is.
I would definitely say using the passive provider
or, alternatively, using network provider,
either one of those would both be a good start.
I’m seeing, I’m going through the reference
guide seeing if I can find what the correct
flags are.
I suspect there is probably a way to do it
but having not done it I don’t know the answer
off the top of my head.
Yeah, I’d say probably the best bet here
would be to go and open up a question on stack
overflow and then post your question to there
with as much detail as you can and then post
a link to your stack overflow question in
the comments for this show and we can go ahead
and research some more information for you
offline and get you a proper, thoroughly researched
answer that will find the solution for you.
>>Lucio: Okay, thanks.
>>Trevor Johns: Yep.
Sorry we can’t answer it just right now but
we will get you an answer.
>>Joe Malin: Okay, thank you.
>>Lucio: Thanks.
>>Daniel Pham: Alright, we have another question
from the hangout.
>>Joe Malin: Alright.
>>Daniel Pham: We’re gonna put the hangout
on again.
>>Joe Malin: Okay.
>>Daniel Pham: Alright, there you go, you’re
on.
Go ahead
>>Male #1: Hello, can you hear me?
>>Joe Malin: Yep.
>>Trevor Johns: Hi.
>>Male #1: Hi, I wanna ask about writing APNS
using code because it wasn’t in gingerbread
it was using a private API that stopped working
for Ice Cream and Jelly Bean.
And I wanted to ask if there was any kind
of replacement that I can use for Ice Cream
and Jelly Bean because here there is local
apps to install APNs because we started sixteen
new mobile carriers in the past six months.
>>Trevor Johns: So, I think the answer there
is APNs should strictly come from the sim
card and we don’t normally want the users
to be adding those manually, of course the
functionality is buried deep in system settings
if it’s something you really need to do but
most of the time this is something the cell
provider should be doing.
It’s not a good user experience to have to
set all these settings.
And there is a way to go and bundle APNs with
a sim card.
So, cell providers just need to make sure
they’re shipping sim cards that actually
contain correct data on them.
And I’m not aware of a work around that will
let you specify APNs otherwise.
>>Male #1: Okay, so I need to contact my carrier
and see if they doing something about it?
>>Trevor Johns: Correct.
>>Male #1: Okay, thank you.
>>Trevor Johns: Sure.
>>Daniel Pham: Alright, that’s it from the
hangout for now guys.
>>Joe Malin: Okay, great.
Thank you very much everyone, we’ll move
back to moderator.
The next question is, “How does Google Music
zoom through scrolling lists so fast?
The images are empty until the scrolling slows
down then the images begin to fade in.
It’s fast and looks great.
Is this only possible in Jelly Bean?
How’s this done?”
>>Trevor Johns: Okay.
I can take that.
So, the answer here is that you wanna make
sure that you’re loading your images asynchronously
off the UI thread.
And, you can do this; the simplest way is
to do an async task.
It’s not the most intelligent way but it’ll
get you 95 percent of the way there.
The only thing you have to be aware of when
you’re async task, when you’re using an
async task is it’s not gonna be aware of
which things have already scrolled off the
screen so it’s not as efficient as you could
be if you wrote some more finely tuned code.
You can actually, there’s a lot of actually
different ways you can do this, you can do
it with a handler or you can, there’s another
way that you can do it too which is escaping
my memory.
One of the developer advocates here, Dan Galpin,
is actually working on a training course that
goes into extreme detail and all the different
ways you can do exactly what you’re describing
right there.
But, I’d say, first step would be start with
an async task, just go and feed a handle to
your list item into the data for the async
task and have it load your imaging asynchronously
and as soon as it’s ready, update your list
view.
And, if you want you could put some place
holder image in there or if you wanna get
fancy you could go and tie in with the animation
framework and that’ll get you that nice fade
effect you want.
If you need some code to get started, since
Dan’s training course isn’t available yet,
I actually did a code lab at Google OI on
exactly this topic, so if you go to, oh I
just moved it actually, if you go to the Google
IO website, go to, so I believe that’s code.Google.com/IO,
possibly?
That sounds about right.
Search for Google IO.
Go to code labs and you’ll see a code lab
from me, Trevor Johns, that’ll, I believe
it’s called Android developer tools boot
camp.
I will add that what you’re trying to do
is not the focus of the code lab but that
sample code provided did tackle this issue.
So go there, once again, Android developer
tools boot camp on the code lab section and
on the right hand side you’ll see a link
to download the slides and inside of the slides
you’ll find a link to the sample code.
Check that sample code out and you’ll see
some code that’ll do exactly what you’d
like to do.
So, hopefully that helps.
>>Joe Malin: Yeah, okay.
Did you use thread pulls and caching in that
example?
>>Trevor Johns: Ah, I didn’t.
Those were the other things that I was, that
I was trying to remember.
So, actually, did I use caching?
I did some in memory caching.
So, that is another thing you have to watch
out for if you’re fetching images from the
network or you’re resizing images, things
like that, caching is something you’ll definitely
wanna keep in mind to keep CPU consumption
low.
Thread pulls are certainly a good way to go
and improve the performance of all this.
So, again, lots of different ways you can
do it.
It’s, but the key thing you need to know
is you need to move your image loading out
of the UI thread.
>>Joe Malin: Absolutely.
>>Trevor Johns: Any mechanism you can use
to do that, moving the image out of the UI
thread, and you’ll get the nice, better smooth
scrolling and that’s just simply a matter
of how do you wanna go and display this data
when it comes it.
Do you wanna do a fade?
Do you wanna a spinner?
What should your place holder image be?
You know, that’s all decisions that’s up
to you as an application developer.
>>Alex Lucas: One other thing I noticed, I
don’t know if this is true but he mentioned
that it, it scrolls, like while it’s scrolling
quickly none of the images are getting loaded
and it waits until it slows down before loading
images.
I was just poking around on the internet to
figure out how this is done and basically
if you wanna set that up so that it doesn’t
bother loading images until the scrolling
slows down, what you wanna do is override
the on scroll method in the, “create an on
scroll listener, override the on scroll method"
and that’s gonna pass you a first visible
item variable.
What you’re gonna do is check for the last
time the method was called to use to like
get the current time to figure out the delta
in time between calls to on scroll and check
the first visible items so that you can, what
this will give you is the number of items
that have scrolled passed and in the past
10 milliseconds or 100 milliseconds or whatever,
as soon as that crosses a threshold or you
feel like okay that’s slow enough let’s
start loading images then implement the things
that Trevor was suggesting with the off thread
caching cause it’s, it would make sense that
if you’re shooting past the first half of
like a thousand item list then you don’t
wanna be loading a thousand thumbnails in
the background.
>>Trevor Johns: Sounds like a good opportunity
for somebody to go write an open source helper
library for all of this.
>>Alex Lucas: Yeah.
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Alex Lucas: I’m putting you in charge of
that, by the way.
[Laughter]
>>Alex Lucas: Go nuts.
>>Joe Malin: Any other comments about this?
Got some good information there.
Okay, we’ll move on in moderator.
Concerning privacy, this is an interesting
one, “Concerning privacy I’d love to see
changes in Android that would forbid developers
to retrieve any unique identifier from the
phone without explicit permission.” My response
is first of all, of course, if you want that
you should submit a feature request and I’d
like the panel to comment on that.
>>Trevor Johns: Um, I’m pretty sure there’s
actually already a feature request open if
you search through Android.com.
>>Joe Malin: Okay.
>>Trevor Johns: With that, yeah, find the
actual existing feature request and star it.
As we’ve mentioned in the past we use the
number of stars as a voting mechanism; the
items that are starred the most are the ones
that get the most visibility which isn’t
to say we don’t look at the others too but
it lets us know how popular something is.
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Trevor Johns: So we do have various controls
in place to make sure that the more sensitive
identifiers are not exposed.
So the IMEI is inside the phone state property
and there is some rather scary, yeah I know
>>Joe Malin: It’s on there.
>>Alex Lucas: It’s explicitly called out
as an awkward place to put that.
>>Trevor Johns: It is.
We do have some scary warning text around
it which is, in my mind, completely appropriate
because that is a scary thing to access, as
well as the other information you can get
with that property is also things you’re
warning the user about.
There is certainly an argument that we should
move this into a different permission entirely
and I think that’s valid but it’s not something
that’s been implemented yet.
So, again, an excellent feature request there.
I will add that the other non secured identifiers
on the phone which would typically be the
Android secure ID, is not a terribly sensitive
permission in that it is; there is a way to
reset it.
It’s a little awkward; it’s reset every
time you do a factory reset.
But there is at least a way to, you know,
it’s not as immutable as a hardware ID is,
so there is that.
Now, that said, I totally agree with you that
the correct way to do this is to have each
application generate their own UU ID and then
make sure that, you know, that way there’s
nothing you can correlate between apps.
I absolutely agree, I’ve actually filed feature
requests about this myself so maybe at some
point in the future we might see this but
we can’t talk about the road map so I can’t
tell you what is or is not coming.
But, that said, we do have a very, very lengthy
blog post that goes into a lot of detail trying
to encourage developers to do the right thing
and, in general as an app developer try, for
your own user’s privacy, try and limit the
scope of what type of identifier you’re requesting.
>>Joe Malin: Right.
[Pause]
>>Joe Malin: I would agree with that wholeheartedly,
in fact, I found this is an interesting question
because there’s lots of developers that also
contact us saying how, what can I use as a
unique identifier for the device?
And, in general, following along with Trevor’s
comments, we say don’t do that for a variety
of reasons.
I think my experience has been that developers
are looking for this as a way of securing
the device against, securing the device for
various reasons like making sure that there’s
not software piracy and things like that.
The problem is is that you, that these things,
as pointed out by this question, can become
security issues.
So, generating a unique UUID or some other
sort of unique thing that was gonna be unique
for your app for that device is a better way
of approaching it.
Any other comments?
No, alright.
>>Daniel Pham: We have Lucio on the hangout
again.
>>Joe Malin: Go ahead.
>>Daniel Pham: Hey, Lucio, you’re back on.
>>Joe Malin: Hey.
>>Lucio: Okay, I have an application that
needs lots of external research like images,
text files, videos and I have to download
them to access it offline but the client doesn’t
want it to be accessible to everyone on the
SD card.
So I’d like to know about techniques to encrypt
them and encrypt on the flag.
What would I use, something like a special
kind of provide or something?
>>Trevor Johns: I’m sorry, what type of resources
are you using again?
>>Lucio: its images, texts, videos.
>>Trevor Johns: Okay.
>>Lucio: basically image, text and video.
>>Trevor Johns: Alright so you wanna take,
basically you’re downloading various content
and you’re storing it to the SD card but
you wanna keep it restricted to your app.
>>Lucio: Sorry, the sound.
>>Trevor Johns: Yeah, I think I’m muted,
Dan.
Daniel?
I’m input 1 or no?
Oh, alright, here I can try and talk louder
is this any better?
>>Lucio: Yeah.
>>Trevor Johns: Okay, I’m like shoving the
mic in my face here.
[Laughs]
>>Trevor Johns: Alright, so basically you
have all this content which is potentially
large, correct?
Cause it’s images and you’re storing them
to the SD card and you wanna restrict them
to your app, correct?
>>Lucio: Yes.
>>Trevor Johns: Okay, so first things first,
for those who are watching if you, again,
if you can store data to internal storage,
you have the ability to use file permissions
and that’s the way to go and keep data, you
know, private within your app.
Anything you write to the SD card, though,
is potentially viewable by any other application.
There’s not an easy way around this.
There are some techniques you can use.
I know, again, somebody on our team has been
working on a mechanism to generate a dynamic
file system and store it inside an encrypted
file.
We do have some mechanisms like OBB, if you
search through the system, that supports some
of this but they’re not well documented and
they’re not very easy to use.
So, with that in mind you could just always
take your data and, again, run it through
some sort of symmetric cipher like AES and
write it out and then when you read it back
in you can decrypt it the same way.
The thing you have to keep in mind though
is just you’re gonna have to have as much
space in memory, you know, for the complete
decrypted content, oh actually even then you
could probably stream it out decrypted U stream.
Yeah, so I suggest not encrypting, yeah so
I’d just say take a look at the crypto libraries,
I believe it’s in, I’m trying to remember
where it’s located.
Java.security, right?
Don’t quote me on that.
But, take a look through the system.
You can find the, um, there are built in ways
to perform AES encryption and just go and
run your data in and out of that as you write
it to disc and that’ll make sure it’s encrypted.
One more thing I would caution is make sure
that you’re changing the file extensions.
Don’t use the default Jpeg, PNG etcetera
extensions cause otherwise media scanner is
gonna pick up on those and try and read your
content then.
Even if it is encrypted it’s still gonna
try and read them and that’s gonna cause
errors.
So, if it’s not a readable file make sure
that it’s not something that looks like a
readable file.
Call it PNGX or something.
>>Lucio: I watched something in user content
profile [cannot understand], I forgot the
name, so it’s encrypted and down to the other
side the encrypted the stream so I just want
to know if that’s possible.
[Laughs]
><>Trevor Johns: Yes.
Absolutely that’s possible.
Actually, on top of that there’s some good
mechanisms you can use to go and make sure
that content provider stays private.
So you can, first off, I believe is it Android
exported or--
>>Joe Malin: Yeah.
>>Trevor Johns: There’s a flag that you can
up, it is?
>>Joe Malin: It’s exported.
>>Trevor Johns: Yeah, so you can set Android
exported equals false to make sure that your
content provider is not visible outside of
your application.
And if you do wanna make it visible, say to
other applications that you’ve developed;
you can also add a custom permission onto
it that’s guarded by a signature.
So only applications that use your signature
will be able to access that content provider
and so, that way your content provider which
is due to your encryption, will only be accessible
to you.
>>Lucio: Okay, thanks.
>>Trevor Johns: Yep.
>>Joe Malin: Okay.
Thank you.
That was an interesting question, yes.
Anybody else on the hangout?
>>Daniel Pham: Nope.
>>Joe Malin: Okay, let’s move forward in
moderator.
“When are you gonna handle .APK file splitting
for over 50 megabyte files on the Google Play
server side instead of having developers worry
about this?”
>>Alex Lucas: Like me personally?
>>Joe Malin: Are you personally worried about
this?
>>Alex Lucas: I’m not really, no.
>>Joe Malin: Okay.
>>Alex Lucas: Okay.
[Laughs]
>>Joe Malin: I guess it’s Google as a whole.
>>Alex Lucas: Okay, to sort of split the question
in sub parts, first of all, uploading, for
instance, a 200 megabyte, let’s say, APK
and having our servers magically chop it up
into smaller pieces that are gonna play nicely
together, I guess do the OBB separation server
side and then alter the code, I guess, that’s
just not gonna work.
There’s no way that we can inspect an APK,
split it up into sub pieces, predict the way
that the developer is intended for the code
to access the resources and then ,and then
just like turn it into an OBB.
That’s gonna work hind side.
We do have certain facilities in place, I
assume when you mean, when you refer to having
the developers worry about this you mean the
OBB functionality.
We have a lot of, we have Dan Galpin, one
of our teammates wrote some really great sample
code and the library, like really great help
for library, that’s downloadable via the
SDK that makes implementing OBB actually not
very hard at all.
It does the virtual file systems stuff, the
zipping, like the little progress bars just
handles all that stuff for you.
We also implemented server side diffs; diffing
so that when you release an update to your
application only the difference from the previous
version gets downloaded on to the client device.
I think that was turned on like very recently,
right?
>>Trevor Johns: Yes, I believe that was turned
on for Jelly Bean.
>>Joe Malin: Jelly Bean.
>>Alex Lucas: Jelly Bean, okay.
>>Trevor Johns: Paid apps on Jelly Bean.
>>Alex Lucas: Paid apps on Jelly Bean, okay.
So not for all devices and all versions but
the, I guess this required a certain amount
of framework support to implement, so, it’s
not quite back portable.
But going forward, diffs are available there.
>>Trevor Johns: Actually, wait, I think back,
the diffs are for all apps on Jelly Bean.
Yeah, not just paid.
>>Alex Lucas: All apps on Jelly Bean.
>>Trevor Johns: All apps on Jelly Bean.
I was thinking of the encryption.
>>Alex Lucas: Right, the encryption is paid
only but diffs are
>>Trevor Johns: Diffs are for all apps on
Jelly Bean and above.
>>Alex Lucas: Great.
Okay.
>>Trevor Johns: I’ll also; I’ll add one
more comments here and maybe cast a little
bit of light on why things behave the way
they do.
So when you download an APK, there is a dedicated
partition in your phone called decache partition
and that’s where the APK is stored before
it’s installed.
And, on most phones, the cache partition,
historically, has been limited to 50 megabytes.
And that’s where that 50 megabyte limit comes
from.
So if you try and install an APK that’s larger
than 50 megabytes it does not fit in the cache
partition and the download fails.
So this is a technical limitation of Android
devices.
Like Alex said, we can’t, you know, magically
split your APKs up into smaller chunks and
we similarly can’t accept a large APK and
try and push that to devices because devices
physically cannot accept a larger APK.
So that, hopefully that at least explains
why things are the way they are.
Alright, let’s move onto the next question.
>>Joe Malin: Alright, I’m right there.
“Do you plan on adding an FM tuner API?
It’s the only phone hardware that lacks proper
Android support and as a result are hardly
any apps for FM radio.” The issue is quite
popular and it cites code.Google.com, issues
detail, so I’m assuming that there’s a feature
request that’s been very popular.
Comments?
>>Trevor Johns: We can’t talk about the Android
road map so, you know, the feature request
is definitely in the system, we’re aware
of it but I can’t tell you what our plans
are going forward.
>>Joe Malin: Right, we don’t have, we don’t
even have the time machine sitting here right
now.
[Laughter]
>>Joe Malin: I think it’s on one of the back
shelves.
That’s how broken it is.
>>Alex Lucas: Either that or it’s working
and it’s somewhere else.
>>Joe Malin: Right, it’s off some place.
>>Alex Lucas: Yeah, or some time.
>>Joe Malin: Really.
Some time and some place, okay, so we can’t
predict, we can’t comment about the future
and we’ll have to move on to the next question.
“I’m trying to draw a larger bit map on
canvas.
When I scale I’m having a hard time scaling
while keeping the central point constant.
I’m doing a canvas.save, canvas.scale and
I need a little help with the canvas.translate.”
>>Trevor Johns: Yes and inside the comments,
Adam, the person which originally asked the
question, posted a large block of code.
>>Joe Malin: Yeah, oh, yeah he did.
>>Trevor Johns: So, unfortunately I don’t
think we’re gonna be able to, this is another
one where we can’t answer it on the air but,
because we’re gonna have to sit down with
a white board and figure out what you’re
doing.
[Laughs]
>>Trevor Johns: So, I don’t know the answer
off the top of my head.
I think this is another excellent candidate
for opening up a question on stack overflow
and then we can address this offline.
>>Joe Malin: Okay, yes, please post it to
stack overflow.
>>Alex Lucas: Also, please include a link
in the comments on the moderator so we can
then find it on stack overflow.
>>Joe Malin: Right.
Definitely.
“How do you enable a one by one widget to
go in a folder like some of the stock widgets
like the stock content widget?
Is it documented somewhere?
I couldn’t find anything about it in the
API guide overview or search.”
>>Trevor Johns: This is an excellent question
and, unfortunately, I have to admit everyone
here in the studio was stumped as well.
We still are stumped, actually.
We spent, you know, quite a few minutes before
the show trying to figure this out and we
weren’t able to solve it by the time we went
on the air.
So, again, this is another one please post
to the stack overflow and we’ll get back
to you with an answer.
I personally am really curious knowing how
this works myself.
So just hold tight, we’ll get you an answer
but we can’t get you an answer on the air.
>>Joe Malin: Thank you.
We’ll move on.
“Hi, I’d like to sync data using a content
provider but the normal SQLite database does
not fulfill my needs which are for static
columns.
How can I properly implement a content provider
that is using a no SQL database to manage
the incoming data?”
>>Alex Lucas: It’s a little difficult to
answer cause it’s quite a generic question.
There’s nothing about, there’s nothing about
content providers that are particularly optimized
or designed for Sequel databases specific.
>>Trevor Johns: Well, there are parts that
are; the content provider model does have
this notion of columns.
>>Alex Lucas: Oh, right.
>>Trevor Johns: Yeah, you do have a fixed
list of columns and if you don’t have that,
content provider, you have this impedance
mismatch that’s gonna make it a little bit
difficult to use.
Now, I think one way you could do this is
actually just take your data and, you know,
rotate it and make it into key value pairs
so, you know, each key would be a column and
each value would be the contents of that column.
Basically you just have two columns, right,
you’d have your key column, you’d have your
value column and then you’d iterate through
that for each record.
So, you would then have to go two levels deep,
right, you’d have your first record which
would be a pointer to your key value collection
and then you would have a second set, you
know, a second collection of records which
is each key value pair from your table.
Now, I’ll also give a plug to, you know,
there’s things like CouchDB for Android which
I haven’t used personally but it’d be interesting
to see how they go an approach this and whether
or not they provide any functionality for
you out of the box.
But I think that’s gonna be the only way
you can actually solve this while actually
using a content provider.
>>Alex Lucas: Is that solution gonna be generally
workable across all no Sequel?
I mean, are all no Sequel databases structured
roughly the same way?
>>Trevor Johns: Most of them do have the appearance
of, you know, you have a record which contains
a number of fields, you know, which is equivalent
to a column in a Sequel database.
But typically those fields are mutable, right,
you don’t have a fixed scheme for each record
and that’s where the problem comes from.
So, most of them still do have something similar
to a column it’s just that columns can change.
So, that’s where the problem is gonna come
from and most of them do follow that general
model.
>>Joe Malin: Well, but do the number of, just
off the top of my head, do the number of columns
in a record change?
>>Trevor Johns: Yeah, they can.
Now, you could go and just have, you know,
say I’m gonna support up to 20 columns or
up to 200 columns and just name them your
data one, data two, data three and you’d
need some sort of, you’d still need some
way to go and, you know, map those columns
to the actual field names.
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Trevor Johns: But, if it works for your
app that might be a work around.
>>Joe Malin: I was gonna say that if that’s
the sort of thing that you’re talking about,
we use that styled implementation for the
contacts provider which is where we store
contact information that the people app in
Jelly Bean uses that content provider and
it has the concept in its data table of, I’m
not sure how I would put it.
>>Trevor Johns: You have to look up tables
that match column names to--
>>Joe Malin: It’s not really a look up table.
What it is is that data has-- records all
have a fixed number of columns but then the
semantics of the column changes depending
on what the mind type of the record is.
>>Trevor Johns: Right.
>>Joe Malin: So if you read, read a record
and you know that it’s mind type is a phone
mind type then the data one column maps to
something that’s really a phone number.
>>Trevor Johns: Right.
A lot of these databases, even with the, you
know, similar record type, the fields can
change, that’d be difficult.
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Trevor Johns: But if you do have at least
some stability there that might be work around.
One other thing that actually just popped
into my head and I have no clue how this all
actually would work for you, but you could
just, again, go in and find a number of anonymous
columns, data one, data two, data three etcetera,
and place a, you know, the name of the column
as the first part of the value.
So, you know, say you’re storing a person
record, right?
Data one, the value could be first name colon,
you know, John, data two would be last name
colon Doe.
And then read in all of those and then run
each of those through split to go and extract
what the, the type of the field is.
>>Joe Malin: Yeah.
>>Alex Lucas: That sounds like a, I mean that
sounds workable and it does sound like a bit
of a wedge
>>Trevor Johns: Oh, yeah.
>>Alex Lucas: to getting a, like, no sequel
database into sequel lite
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Trevor Johns: Well, Well that’s what you’re
doing; I mean, the provider was modeled around
the idea of a Sequel database.
>>Alex Lucas: Not, you can back end a content
provider with, like let’s say, a file or
shared preferences or something like that,
it’s an abstraction.
>>Trevor Johns: Right, but it’s still gonna
go and, you know, it still has the mechanism
for lookups, you know, there’s still a lot
of stuff in there that assumes you have these
columns and the columns don’t have to map
to a Sequel database but you still do have
a fixed set of columns.
>>Joe Malin: I would say that the idea that
the content provider is, is that it has semantics
for specifying queries and modifications and
it also has semantics for what the return
value, what should be returned and other than
that it doesn’t specify anything about the
implementation.
This means that if you have something which
doesn’t fit into the normal structure of
a sequel lite database then you’re gonna
have to do more work inside the content provider.
And it’s really difficult for us to give
a definitive answer about what that work would
be if, other than being able to look in detail
at your problem.
But, what we’ve covered is, there’s a way
to mimic no SQL databases with SQL like databases
by, you know, using generic columns, is what
I would use.
There’s ways of doing it with storing the
information about a column in the column and
then there’s ways of doing it by just having
a no SQL database within the content provider
and then doing transformations.
>>Trevor Johns: And I’m gonna recommend one
other possible work around here and I feel
guilty recommending this cause it’s not the
Android way but you could actually create
a service and add a binder interface that’ll
let you, you know, actually, you know, transfer
the data in whatever format you like and avoid
the content provider interface.
If you’re exporting your data to other applications
this is probably not the right way to go but
if this data is only being consumed within
your applications then that suddenly becomes
a lot more workable.
Or, even if it does other applications you
could even ship a client library or something
like that but, again, that’s not really the
Android way.
I want to discourage you from doing that but
within the context of your own application
you have a bit more freedom and binder might
be a solution.
>>Joe Malin: I would also encourage you to,
put this question on stack overflow and give
as much detail as possible to the extent that
you can.
The reason that I say that is that this doesn’t
give us very much information about what you’re
trying to do and the problem space very often
suggests solutions that we wouldn’t suggest
otherwise.
First of all you might get somebody else out
there whose solved a similar problem and has
it working or by knowing more about what you’re
actually trying to do we can help you out
as well and, and the rules are generally put
it onto stack overflow and then post the link
into our moderator.
>>Trevor Johns: I like this question, though,
cause it was, it opened up a bit of debate
here.
[Laughter]
>>Alex Lucas: We all have different ways that
we would implement it.
I think you would, you would go with turning
to a sequel lite database, I would go with
skip sequel lite entirely and put all the
work in the content provider.
>>Trevor Johns: I was not saying turn it into
a sequel lite database.
>>Joe Malin: No.
>>Trevor Johns: My answer was you’re putting
all this work into the content provider; it’s
just how are you exposing the data within
the framework that content provider exposes.
>>Alex Lucas: Okay.
Gotcha.
>>Trevor Johns: What is your output gonna
look like given the content provider does
enforce a set of restrictions on how that
can work?
>>Alex Lucas: Okay.
>>Joe Malin: Okay.
I think that just the generalized nature of
content providers does lead to debate.
I would, for instance, debate the idea that
content provider, makes restrictions.
It has a certain set of semantics that give
you a lot of leeway, sometimes they don’t
work.
So, but they’re not meant to be restrictive
and, having said that, I’m gonna go on cause
I’m the moderator.
Ha.
Next question, “I’m creating a gallery with
pinch zoom.
As I see it there are two options; use the
UI toolkit or two, extract parts of Android’s
built in gallery app, it’s open source.
Which approach is recommended?
Or is there another approach that would be
better?”
[Pause]
>>Alex Lucas: Wanna take a crack at this one?
[Laughter]
>>Trevor Johns: Just throw me into the fire
here.
[Laughter]
>>Trevor Johns: Oh boy.
>>Joe Malin: There’s no debate about this
one, Trevor’s gonna answer it.
>>Alex Lucas: Right.
>>Trevor Johns: Pinch Zoom is difficult to
do.
I don’t have any really good recommendations
off the top of my head other than look at
how the existing code does it.
I’m not aware of, there’s probably some
client libraries out there cause it is a common
enough problem but I’m not familiar with
what they are off the top of my head but the
gallery is open source, you are welcome to
go and take parts of it and use it in your
own code and if I were doing this myself,
that’s probably where I’d start.
>>Joe Malin: I would certainly agree.
We’ll move on since we’re running low on
time.
“Is there a way to provide a custom icon
to display when registering for the new action
assistant intent instead of showing the generic
search icon?
If so, what res do the assets need to be and
what are the restrictions, ability to change
your icon and runtime etcetera?”
>>Trevor Johns: So, action assist uses something
called a labeled intent which, unfortunately,
nobody on our team has actually had the pleasure
of working with yet.
As of two hours ago, I’d asked a number of
people and they actually never heard of labeled
intent before.
So, I don’t know the answer yet.
It’s new, I’m really curious again to know
what the answer is here so please post a question
on stack overflow so we can research this
and get an answer to you.
I suspect the answer, well the answer has
to be either you can’t do it or there is
a way to do it.
I’m leaning a little bit more towards the
opinion that it might not be possible but
I’m not a hundred percent sure yet so give
us some more time, post something on stack
overflow and we’ll get you a definitive answer
there from the framework team.
>>Joe Malin: Okay, thank you.
Next question, “Can I, can you point me to
some sample code that I can use to put images
I download within my app from my server, images
taken in my app via camera into an app specific
album similar to how Facebook and many other
apps do it?”
>>Trevor Johns: So, I can’t point you to
sample code cause I’m not aware of any but
I can tell you what you wanna do and what
you wanna do is, well there’s two approaches
you can do, actually.
The easy one is create a folder with a nice
descriptive name on the external storage,
so the SD card, and place your images there
and then media scanner periodically scans
through those and will automatically add those
as a source in gallery.
So that’s the easy way to go about doing
this.
Now, the correct way to go about doing this
is to use the media provider and, you know,
programmatically insert a record for each
of your images into media provider.
Unfortunately the docs on media provider are
pretty sparse.
It is listed in the API reference if you search
for, Android.provider there are some entries
in there for media and that’s what you wanna
go about doing.
Inserting data into any provider is the same
so if you’re using, you know, there’s plenty
of docs on content provider, for example.
That’d probably be a good start if you’re
not familiar with how the provider system
works and then once you’re familiar with
that, read up on media provider and hopefully
that’ll make, make some sense to you.
Yeah, so you’ll basically make a record for
each image you wanna display and there’s
some fields that go an add additional Meta
data.
And that’ll get you, you know, something
a lot similar to what Picasa and Facebook
do cause that’s what they do.
Unfortunately, again, not much in the way
of sample code or documentations specific
to media provider other than what’s in the
API reference.
So, hopefully that gets you at least half
way there.
>>Joe Malin: Thank you again, Trevor.
Question, “With ICS individual notification
peaks were disabled.
Now user needs to open notification drawer
to get notification details.
Is there a specific reason for that decision
about not allowing notification peak view?
I apologize if this is a duplicate.”
>>Trevor Johns: Does anyone know what notification
peak view actually is?
>>Joe Malin: I, the only thing I can think
of is that he’s talking about the expanded
view of notifications.
>>Trevor Johns: Right, but we didn’t have
those in ICS.
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Trevor Johns: Those are new to Jelly Bean.
>>Joe Malin: Yeah.
>>Alex Lucas: I think on like Honeycomb when
you received a, let’s say you got an email,
without, without popping up that notification
list there would be a little, it was almost
like a toast, they would just sort of flash
on “received an email” blah, blah, blah.
>>Trevor Johns: Okay.
>>Alex Lucas: And it would disappear again.
>>Trevor Johns: Which doesn’t work too well
on phones.
>>Alex Lucas: Right.
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Alex Lucas: I’m curious if this is specific
to the phone or 7 inch tablet size or if it
goes all the way to the 10 inch.
>>Trevor Johns: Yeah, it’s possible that
it might just be disabled on phone size devices
which, for the large part, does include Nexus
7, a lot of the phone UI conventions are also
carried to the Nexus 7, for example, your
notification bar is on the top of the screen
as opposed to on the bottom.
So, I’m curious to see if you still see that
behavior on a proper tablet device writing
Jelly Bean.
And, to my knowledge, I haven’t heard anything
about this changing so my gut feeling is it’ll
probably still work.
>>Joe Malin: I would say that there’s no
particular API to either enable or disable
this so it’s probably just a feature of how
large the screen real estate is.
>>Trevor Johns: Right.
>>Joe Malin: And that’s probably why it happened
is that some sort of design decision was made
about how to most effectively show notifications.
Since we’re running low on time I wanna move
forward, here.
“Why should I use the new small width identifier
that is layout SW7 and 20DP when it’s only
available for Android 3.2 plus?
I’m building an app targeting Android 3.0
plus for normal to extra large screen devices.”
>>Trevor Johns: So this is, that’s not small
width that’s smallest width.
>>Joe Malin: Right.
>>Trevor Johns: And the answers to why you
would wanna use it, and it’s not just, you
know, SW320 it’s SW and any number.
And the reason you’d wanna use that is cause
it’s a lot more flexible.
It turns out that there’s this grey area
right around 5 to 7 inches where it’s not
really clear whether or not something is a
tablet or a phone, it’s sort of this tweener
device, is what we sort of informally called
them.
A good example of this would be the Dell streak.
And, depending on the app, sometimes it makes
sense to treat it as a phone, sometimes it
makes sense to treat it as a tablet and sometimes
it makes sense to do an entirely separate
UI.
On top of that, you know, we have the Nexus
7 and then, you know, a large device like
Zoom and, again, you may wanna do different
UIs for those and it’s not, basically the
entire large screen bucket is ambiguous and
then add to that that you now have all these,
you know, a lot of different tablet sizes
as well.
It’s not, it’s not always clear how you
wanna break up your UIs, we just give you
a lot more flexibility, that’s the reason
why is more flexible, we leave the decision
up to you as a developer where it makes sense
to draw the line, where you have a tablet
UI, a phone UI, do you have multiple tablet
UIs?
Do you have multiple phone UIs?
You know, it’s just, using those screen buckets
was too complicated, they’re still there,
we still support them, you’re still welcome
to use them if they work for you keep using
them but keep in mind that the new options
are more flexible.
>>Joe Malin: Okay and I think we’ll take
our last question now, “Input method manager
hides soft input from input method and windows
sets soft input mode window manager layout
param soft input state always hidden, hides
the keyboard.
But views added, window manager, add view,
view params from service does not have a window.
What to do?”
>>Alex Lucas: What to do about what?
>>Joe Malin: Yeah I’m not really clear what
the question is going after.
>>Trevor Johns: Yeah, there seems to be a
clause in your sentence missing there.
>>Joe Malin: Right.
I would suggest, honestly, that you put an
expanded version of this question on stack
overflow and then link into the moderator
so that we can, help you out.
I mean, definitely it looks like there’s
something going on here with input methods
that we can help you out with but not from
the information that we’ve got here.
Okay and, since we didn’t answer that one
let’s try this one last one that doesn’t
have a link to stack overflow.
“I have an app that has a child lock using
a custom launcher, however, when the app is
closed and the home button is pressed, the
dialogue that I ask for the default launcher
is shown.
Is there a way to reset the default launcher
to the Android launcher?” Hm.
>>Trevor Johns: I’m trying to understand
exactly what’s happening here.
So you have this app that inputs a custom
launcher, you close the app by, you know,
I imagine you move to a different app and
then you hit home and then it asks for the
default launcher.
Now, I imagine, was the problem that you picked
your child lock application and set it as
default and now you’re locked into this?
If so, the answer is yes there is certainly
a way to get around this.
You need to get into system preferences and,
your settings excuse me, you need to get into
settings, you need to go to apps, find the
app in question, your child lock app and click
on that and there’ll be a clear defaults
button.
When you push clear defaults it will remove
any saved settings for intents so as for what
the preferred app to handle intent and the
next time you hit the home button you’ll
get that chooser dialogue again and then you
can pick the system launcher.
If, for some reason, you cannot get into system
settings, Android does have a very rarely
discussed but occasionally useful, safe mode
and if my memory serves me correctly, the
way to get into safe mode is to boot up the
phone while holding your finger down in the
middle of the screen and that will prevent
any services that launch in startup from actually
launching and from there you should be able
to get into system settings.
>>Joe Malin: Okay, I hope that answered the
question.
If not we’ll expect to hear from you again.
>>Trevor Johns: And I’ll also add, just as
safe mode is not very well discussed, I don’t
use it very well myself, so it’s entirely
possible that I forgot the correct way to
get into it.
[Laughs]
>>Trevor Johns: If it doesn’t work, do a
search and you’ll find the correct procedure.
>>Joe Malin: Okay.
[Pause]
>>Alex Lucas: We’re over.
>>Joe Malin: Okay I think we’re over so that
does it for today, thank you very much for
joining us.
Thank you for all the questions from the hangouts
etcetera.
>>Trevor Johns: Yep, and--
>>Joe Malin: And we’ll see
>>Trevor Johns: Yeah, go, I was gonna announce
next week
>>Joe Malin: Oh, you have something.
>>Trevor Johns: I do have next week.
Yes, so, yeah, so once again we are on the
air every Wednesday at 2 PM Pacific time.
Be sure to join us next week which is August
29th where we’ll have Bruno Alevara, Adam
Powell and Richard Fulker joining us to discuss
multi versioning UI and UI navigation.
>>Joe Malin: Cool.
>>Trevor Johns: So hopefully we’ll see many
of you there.
>>Alex Lucas: That’s awesome.
>>Joe Malin: Awesome, man.
Until that time, same bat time, same bat station.